well happy saint patty's day happy
saturday happy saint patrick's day no
it's not actually saint patrick's day
oh no
but it will be when this airs yes yeah
we'll drop it on st patrick's day and
celebration of saint patrick
who we all know and love so well yeah
saint patrick uh driving out snakes he
did the thing with the snakes and uh
you know and then people were like
that's cool let's get hammered let's get
hammered about it
speaking of that
yeah yeah but then they were like
where'd our [ __ ] snakes go
[ __ ] are they part of the ecosystem they
work god damn it
they're feeding right the snakes feed
the birds and the
but no snakes there in ireland as is the
case with um i'll look at you coming in
to fix my mic as is the case with hawaii
you know about it yes you know about
this yeah
you know about this
i don't i don't know what you're talking
about no stakes no snakes no snakes they
got like one species of snake which is
more like a worm
so
[Laughter]
a worm is just a snake that is like way
more lame
right you know what i mean it's like
it's like
like all worms want to be snakes you
know what i mean like they're worms like
when i grow up i'm definitely gonna be a
snake dude i know i can make this happen
doesn't work that way yeah walter it
does not work that way wait hold on
walter is that your fist your butt
you face your butt buddy well so so what
are we doing here we're here at night
now for the for the viewer you can see
uh that there's alcohol in front in
front of us
uh the listener you've you've just heard
it you've just heard you there you've
heard it you've heard the words there's
three shots of brown per person
including megan just to get going just
to get going just to get a base
we were asked very often are we drinking
at work and generally i mean almost
always the answer is no there's only
been a cut we've covered this in the
podcast there's been a couple of times
where we've drank during work and
shooting hours only at the very end of
something like it was like the last
scene of a season yeah yeah yeah so we
thought let's drink at work today and
maybe we might do this we might not do
this we were kind of joking around hey
would it be funny for the people
listening or watching to hear us try to
break an episode
and to see how that would go drunk we
may start that and totally give it up
because we don't have to do anything we
don't want to do no and breaking stories
is the worst it's the worst
it's a lot of this
um what what
okay wait
wait wait
what if okay okay no no no
no we did that we did that there's a lot
of we did we did that we did yeah we did
that
we did that
that's a lot of we did that we did that
well let's drink the shots let's get it
going
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do all three shots right in a row
yeah because then that first minute
we'll well all of us will still be sober
then slowly but surely the alcohol will
kick in or quickly i don't know i think
it's going to be pretty now this is uh
this is bourbon
yeah this is a bourbon drink all right
cheers uh there's the irish word right
slandja
yes longe
that sounds like i'm saying isn't that
beyonce's system
[ __ ] it here we go sorry it's a solange
all right
it's lounge
just like that
no rest for the weary let's get right
out we're not you're not even going to
take like a 10 second break between them
you're just gonna no i was just gonna i
was just gonna go first that second one
went down with a pause
yeah there was a hole in your mouth for
a second there was a brief pause where
my body was like
no no don't do that
yeah your body's like no i will not do
stop why are you doing that i'm gonna
drink a sip of water because i'm not
yeah it's just not yeah
that was that's two for me
yep it's gonna be number three i'm doing
a
now just to be clear
that was all the same bourbon
and it was exactly
one shot
in each glass that would be 1.5 ounces
of fluid but it was uh
86 proof
yeah just a hair
stronger just a hair stronger than your
average 80 80 proof alcohol yeah
and we're not in college anymore so that
is this is not a normal routine for us i
don't uh fire down three shots
ever ever for yourself
you're firing down shots
if i do shots it'll be like a tequila or
something like that
guys i figured out actually
the formula to getting drunk without
getting a hangover would you like to
hear what it is yeah yeah that'd be
that'd be good i need that really bad
okay uh now this is not to say that you
won't have like you might have a little
bit of a hangover but i i i'll say it's
it's the formula that i've figured out
that gives me the least amount of
hangover
no it's the shots are fine it's
it's the potato chips you gave us
beforehand
have created a very salty very quick
sort of salty heart burning situation oh
no yeah
your body's just rejecting all of it
i'm fine but i mean i mean it wasn't
just potato chips that were
yeah there was there was other things
but there was the saltiness of this
potato it ended with just also for the
listener at home and the viewer we are
in my in my home yeah this is my guest
this is cozy this is my office this is
the my office that i that i work out of
we didn't think it'd be fun to do it at
our
uh
you will you will notice again for the
listener they don't know that it's not 9
a.m
you can tell when you look out here in
the camera that it's dark outside yeah
we decided to do this at night
normally we record the podcast in the
morning megan did you just wiggle your
glass to indicate to me you you just got
the third one down the third one that's
still very impressive that is a lot of
whiskey to drink very fast
okay
i wanted to do it in the mic because
that's part of the fun is there a trash
can close by in case it comes up this
might come up it might come up no that
was just
you guys have not spent a lot of time
drinking you've spent a lot of time with
megan but not a lot of time drinking
with megan i have spent time drinking
with megan she gets so
happy oh are you a happy happy drunk
she's a happy happy drunk
already so happy i know you as a happy
person in general oh my god
megan is a happy person but there are
demons wow you're a person whiskey
pushes the demons away never have bad
like drug experiences or drinking
experience i don't go dark when i use it
ever no no no no no no substance is made
you go no no i i keep trying
i took so many mushrooms recently and
like way too many and i was still like
it was like overpowering but i was still
like this is cool this is fun yeah okay
let's get into that that's fascinating
because you you do go dark sober well
that's because uh and i've been reading
eckhart tolle recently oh that's me yeah
yes that's the second time
has come up rob and i are big fans of
eckhart tolle i just started reading it
at um caitlyn actually suggested that i
start listening to it the power of now
which i've never listened to before
but i think that that's because when i'm
sober it's my like
thinking mind
that is sad all the time and when i get
drunk maybe that it's your ego it's your
ego it's it's the eye that you identify
with not the real you but the
yes now but he addresses this i'm not
going to plug or push eckhart toronto i
will say that he addresses this because
he said what he says is
you you try to rise above the voice
and drinking
you're basically uh you're dropping
below the voice yeah either way the
voice is gone oh the thing is if you go
above the wall eckhart talks about that
he talks about very specifically about
alcohol drugs whatever it is because you
can quell the voices that's from his
point of view
yeah it's also running away substances
is like you running away from the ever
present now
of you being just in the moment that
you're in yes sure
and yet
god damn it makes you happy yeah in
short bursts
and for a minute so like it's releasing
a bun it's dumping a bunch of like
dopamine right or endorphins or
something into your brain for a second
and then is there you got some science
to back that up no no no no i don't
think it releases any dopamine
i don't know i don't know it does
something to make you happier it
releases something more sad better first
one
i was trying to match you but it was
good no it wasn't
just like the show
don't try to keep up being your own self
thank you hey rob just sounds like erica
the the ladies and gentlemen the alcohol
is
[Music]
can we open the door no no no no take
your shirt off take your shirt turn the
fire off no take your shirt off you
don't want me to take my shirt off glenn
what do you sit over here then don't
because are you a fatty
are you a fatigue
boy i rab your nose is a little red i
was out i was out in the wind well i was
out in the wind again
oh i have wind burn or maybe that's i
don't know dude i definitely have wind
burn we don't know
wind burn just on your nose no no no no
that's literally alcohol what was that
blush yeah your flashlight was my note
was my nose red before the alcohol no
it is fired up since
it looks like someone has slapped
another nose onto your face like that
you know what it is i think it's the i
think it's the fire
[Music]
remember when you're a kid and there was
a rumor that like hey man don't pee in
this pool because they put a chemical
yeah yeah if you pee it like turns like
blue around you and then you pee well
it's it's for you
it is it is if he's been drinking that's
how he gets caught yeah and it's
hereditary
have you noticed it before no i'd do it
a bit i would like
okay we have just figured it out yes we
have just figured out why we don't break
stories drugs
there's no i have no desire i'm sweating
no i'm not going to no we're not going
to do it we're not going to do it i
would like to hear you play that guitar
though at some point i'm just all right
yes straight into it
just one pound one prompt what do you
want we'll make up things um
yeah make up make it up you know what
sing it let's sing sing about our
friendship
[Music]
nose rock
[Laughter]
i don't know that's all i got
yeah that's fair it's kicking in now and
he's getting real
see this is the problem yeah yeah yeah
the problem sloppy it's sloppy sloppy
you guys are the beatles
wait where the middles go
okay okay
i forgot that we were the beatles go
right oh he's got a guitar where's my
guitar
there's
it's like when bob dylan went electric
you know what i mean nobody wants it
nobody wants it
there we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
here's what's interesting the alcohol
works yeah
let's break a story well hold on a
second hold on
hold
on
hold on
hold on
[Music]
hold on
hold
i've on holding my life
and holding just feels wrong
[Music]
we got you beer
yeah you want to reach behind there i
want to sit but well yeah you got there
and now you want to sip on something and
maintain i don't know that i've ever had
whiskey without the beer oh so it's okay
yeah
all right really
yeah what guinness goes light what do
you want well it's say patty's day give
me the guinness give get the man a
guinness give the man again again the
the guinness first of all should we
should this just be podcasting now yeah
yeah yeah he should be on the episode of
the podcast definitely not
yeah
i mean i want one i want one set up
another one
wait i gotta hold my hand because we're
gonna break a story this is a whiteboard
oh i thought that was i thought you were
gonna like uh it looks like a like
you're a basketball coach hey rob now
that we're not sitting by the fire i'm
waiting can you close the door
no because that's what's gonna that's
what's got your nose
it's gonna de-heat me your nose has
calmed down i told you it's because i'm
so [ __ ] hot why would your nose get
hotter than everything indicates when
there's a fire
it's like a fire alarm okay that's what
the episode should be about okay okay
here we go here we go here we go
okay okay so which character is it whose
nose constantly turns red and they're
upset about it well rob's no no it's
dennis's right because it it like
it [ __ ] with your ego that your nose
turns red
like you're like and so my
embrace no level of makeup will cover
your nose right right or or such a level
of makeup that you can see it and once
you start to see it you know the
illusion is gone right if you know that
i'm wearing makeup then the illusion is
good yeah and that by the way that is
the that is the it's like uh his nose is
turning red again i'm like
you know i thought you were dealing with
that with makeup
you know and then i go on a whole
monologue about uh
about how no amount of makeup you know
the the amount of makeup that it would
take nowadays to make the nose not be
red is you know it becomes noticeable
you can see it okay and that's a problem
that's a problem that's a problem so
maybe his nose has been read for you for
years yeah yeah but he's been covering
it up well we've done it so he's done
that we've established he was make-up
free in an episode and it wasn't red it
was ghoulish this is where we started
there's something
this is where we run into problems with
the history
yeah that's not video that episode oh so
it doesn't exist so we can do it again
again it does exist it's on youtube
that's scenes on youtube okay somebody
put that put it on youtube that metal
chart you have
the middle part it just makes that whole
thing we we were trying to figure out
episode got taken down
yeah so actually why
well because it's it's d it's d-day oh
it's tasteless
yeah
coming out
everybody the guitar is coming back out
i'm just gonna noodle while we talk he
likes it
i know can i [ __ ] with your tuning yeah
that yes of course
you can do whatever you want but that's
what i like to do this is like this is
like story breaking in the sunny room
except that glenn you need those
remember those weighted baton things you
had oh yeah yeah those like what were
those they were like weights but then
you could swim there were indian clubs
yeah the indian clubs that you swing
around and that's for forearm strength
or
uh
this is like
he doesn't know what it's for that's the
thing it's always a new thing
can we um i i hate the red-nosed episode
there's something better we can do of
course
we haven't even started there's nothing
he determines there's nothing on the
whiteboard he determined that he didn't
like it once i started playing
yourself getting cooler
and so i'm wondering about my nose
your nose looks better
interesting
that isn't your perspective by the way
the the how it goes is you drink and you
drink and you drink your nose gets
redder and red or redder then the
vessels start exploding and that's you
know when you see those guys yeah those
people that have wc fields or something
yeah where the nose is like exploding in
different places the blood vessels yeah
what is that why is it the nose
specifically that that takes on takes
the brunt of it
when you when you drink too much like
the liver sends it to the [ __ ] nose
and then you get varicose vein veins in
the nose what is the liver nose
connection what's the liver nose
connection guys there's so many
mysteries in science that we haven't
even scratched the surface the liver
nose connection
guys can we do let's do the shot
let's write a book called the liver nose
connection uh do you want to let's do
the shot oh yeah yeah yeah we gotta give
him a shot okay yeah guys
he didn't want him initially but he
wasn't there
yeah i thought you wanted he wants the
beer too i want both men
do you guys want to hear how to get
drunk without a hangover oh my god you
set that up and we believe i know that's
okay that's all right i'm i'm going with
the flow but but it just came back to me
and i realized i do want to tell this
because i think our listeners are going
to want to know or at least
humans have been drinking for thousands
of years but you wow
no ceremony whatsoever
he's passed ceremony
for the listener at home or in the car
charlie just took the shot the rest of
us are sitting here waiting well for him
to get his alcohol so that we could all
solange
i wanted it i wanted it
that that sounds like the camera
everybody bought charlie i just wanted
it
no i wanted to do it while i still had
the spirit to do it because um you know
you might start telling your story and
then suddenly i don't want to do it you
know what's coming out in me already is
when i get drunk i wink a lot at people
oh it's as dangerous as the ladies yeah
it is you know who hates winking is
caitlyn
she [ __ ] yeah and i do it to her all
the time just because it makes her
cringe
like i'll like i'll say something that i
that's like that i recognize as like
cheesy funny and i'll give her like a
little just a quick like a little you
know a quick wink and she's just like oh
like it goes through her body like i see
that i see it like
like she just
she she can't and she doesn't like
accents people doing she hates accents
accents uh i'm texting we've had ours if
you want yours to have it but take your
time but
this must be i wonder if this is the
best episode to listen to or the [ __ ]
worst
i think i think if anything um it could
be slightly novel but i definitely don't
think we should fool ourselves and think
that this is
but yeah of course i'm going to start
slurring my words all right but for the
listener at home he's going crazy
because most people would love to be
able to have a drink and never get hung
over what's the secret oh okay okay okay
um
thank you for the prompt oh for [ __ ]
all right all right all right all right
suddenly got very sober right all right
oh god oh that's not fun i just want to
hear your answer then i'll go okay all
right here we go i'm gonna i'm gonna
make this fast because i'm afraid i'm
gonna lose rob and you know his nose is
gonna generally losing me you're losing
the audience no no no no no no no i'm
not i swear to god i'm no bodies
i can feel it i know where they are
they're right here you know for the
listener you can't see this but i'm
circling my palm you're in the palm of
my hand right now i can feel it
um okay so here's how you do it
you go to you let's say you're at a
party right you're or you're at a bar
okay you want to get drunk but you don't
want to get a hangover okay and you want
a clean buzz
okay so
you want a clean buzz because a clean
buzz yeah it's pure it's pure
pure all right so you want to drink a
clear liquor and i would advise vodka
okay here's what you do you go to the
bar and you order a shot of vodka
and a water
okay you drink you do the shot of vodka
you drink the [ __ ] water
then you get another shot of vodka but
every time you get a shot of vodka you
drink a bottle of water
oh [ __ ] is that the russians is that the
russians
it's the helicopter
is this a red dawn situation it could be
oh we might by the way i'm ready you're
right are you yeah yeah i am too yeah
i am too we believe in the second
amendment the mackerel buddy i am armed
but not when you're drinking
what do you mean you're not got that
when you're drinking the guns don't go
away they stay where they are in the
safe
yes
[Laughter]
drink a lot of water when you drink well
by the way
yes yes that that's the gist
i think somebody told me that at 16.
if someone told me me that out of 20
would have helped a lot
i'm telling you guys i'm telling you
guys and i i did this experiment with
jill too and jill
now this is what she will do sometimes
when she needs to stay like
you know sharp
there it is
at a party
you know yeah go for it
[Music]
what jail stays short
[Laughter]
okay can i i'd like to do
get on mike what would you like to do
i'd like to do a reveal
i'd like to do a reveal of my ears
oh oh [ __ ] are your ears on my ears so
are so hot they're on fire
yeah so i think my nose is going to calm
down but my ears let's do it
let's see it
i'll wait for my mom
they're not red no they feel so hot
i'm so hot
right out the window
that blows the hot [ __ ] nose because
what you were implying by saying that
you
know this is looking red to me because
i'm irish
he's an irishman
and sometimes our noses
get rather than we planned
if you wanna pick your kid up
from school
but your nose is looking red it's gonna
look like a fool
cause they know you've been drinking
and you're drunk
[Music]
you've been drinking
[Music]
oh that was that's like that's not just
falsetto that's a gib that's like beyond
falsetto
yeah yeah man
yeah oh so by the way okay so for the
watcher listener at home
um
when we do get drunk together and it's
been a while we don't we don't do it but
we used to do it in the early seasons we
did it all the time we [ __ ] party and
drink all the time
and if there was a piano or a guitar
nearby this
is exactly the kind of thing that would
happen
i remember being over at danny's house
you would always sit down at the piano
and start
you know just and i was always so
jealous of that it's my happy place this
is my happy place yeah i did it all
through college too like oh really
i was faster it's quicker that's in the
hallway and just make up songs about
people as they walk by i i would yeah i
don't know i i need to get it out of my
system that was good for girls though
right
good for attracting uh you know what it
was and
i was no good at attracting women until
i picked up a guitar and then i was like
oh that works yeah so
i have a theory about why that is
yeah okay so i feel the same about dance
like why so many women were into magic
mike and also why women are into men
that play instruments yeah i think it's
because like there's a thing about
masculinity that you can't express
emotions and stay masculine at the same
time
having an instrument or doing dance as a
way of expressing emotions that's like
considered
within the realms of masculinity yeah
absolutely
i think you are absolutely right yeah
thank you
i think she's absolutely right you never
say that to me rob
and that's why he's laughing right now
because he's like why are you so dumb
validate a woman how condescending it is
he's telling you how right you are i am
right why is that condescending because
you're a man telling a woman that she is
right about why women are attracted to
men
no no no no you know you're wrong no i
don't you're wrong that's crazy that's
crazy you're [ __ ] that's chris
[Laughter]
this is it don't yeah oh
that's the that's why i said doesn't do
whiskey that's why i
i know you are i was validating megan's
point of view because i agreed with it
it's just that simple
she said something she said something
and i was like oh [ __ ] you're totally
right and i would have said that to
anyone
man woman alien
ross
[Laughter]
he's in his own category people don't
even know about ross he's in his own
category next level podcast
get the shot ross stick your stick your
[ __ ] face and megan's shot let's
let's have a look at ross it's gonna
take over for me when i moved to that
chair because connie's house yeah yeah
he's gone
you're going for a podcast
okay this is ross maloney uh this man
has
uh
he's my rock
so i'm gonna get emotional
rust
is my rock
[Laughter]
do you need a tissue man i can go
running i'm good
i'm gonna get you a tissue
ross is my rock ross is my rock is a
good lyric yeah it is yeah russ is my
rock he is that's my rock he really is
when i need a man to jump in for me russ
is my rock
when i have a proper lisa
it's also been very helpful to me by the
way with the podcast and he helped me
set up today and also he uh wrote down
some questions that we could ask you
guys hey let's do that yeah let's do
some prompts um
so one of them is which of you guys is
the most fun drunk and how would you
categorize it
but i think we're all equally fun
i agree we're we're all i think we're
all happy drunks
ross you're the one sober person in this
situation now yeah oh [ __ ] i haven't
done my shot oh
my god hey guys lord i'm hammered i
didn't eat dinner
i'm ready for another one
ah you're [ __ ] nuts all right i'll do
it i'm gonna do it this is gonna get
real it's gonna get messy you sat in but
you haven't spoken
who's the best drunk
he doesn't even know us
he's glenn's rock tonight
no you know what ross it's not fair for
you to because glenn might fire you
glenn pays you i don't pay you [ __ ] i
wouldn't fire ross for a million dollars
let the man speak all right what's
what's take on it uh okay i'm seeing
different styles emerge here i i like
the musical comedy but then the
aggression i i was into it i couldn't
look away
i shot down the aggression i should have
let that flare up the question's fun ah
that's not real rob you were out of
glenn because of why
what else exactly well uh uh
i
i want to see it like you know let's
let's let's see what happens again right
you want another shot i i'd be happy to
pull yeah i think we should probably do
another shot if we're gonna if we're
here at st patrick's day let's do
another shot
look i'm the only one that's gonna work
tomorrow what do you mean i'm looking
you don't know that
dario
how dare you told me i didn't tell you
[ __ ] yes you did you're on a sabbatical
sorta
yeah but guess what i'm looking you're
right
but i didn't tell you that yes you did
no i'm not on sabbatical i was supposed
to be there you're working tomorrow
yeah of course no no i am i am i am
i got yo dude you guys all have kids
your work everybody we gotta get up i
gotta we gotta take the kids to school
100
yeah yeah yeah it's brutal
but i wake up every morning super early
and meditate
that's gonna be hard dude
all right rustic man
[Laughter]
yes
you're gonna officially join
us that means you're taking the wheel
with the ones and the zeros pal oh yeah
but yeah no but but it's gotta be one
point you gotta measure it out so it's
it's an equal shot all the way across uh
no
he doesn't have to oh i see
it is it is can you unplug it can you
just can you do like you have another
acoustic
yeah of course i got it
uh i'm good i'm i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna do one right now this is foolish
by the way this is foolish
by the way when you say you have to work
tomorrow what are you doing you breaking
stories breaking stories buddy
we are
in a safe space we are we're all driven
here
oh yeah i think it's important
we ubered i live here for this theme of
saint patrick's day i wrote you guys
some toasts which we can do with this
shot
in the style of a limerick
oh so you wrote these i wrote these
limericks for each of you but i think
that you shouldn't read the one that's
about you you should read one that's
about i agree have you ever you ever
heard like um uh drinking limericks like
my favorite one was in this movie um
gentlemen prefer blondes which is my
favorite movie
and uh meryl monroe
before they take a drink she she recites
this limerick which is uh there was an
old fellow from sydney who drank till he
ruined a kidney it shriveled and shrank
but he drank and he drank he had his fun
doing it didn't he
yeah that's pretty good except it would
be the liver wouldn't it
not the kidneys
connection
yeah i could credit for that because
totally right get your [ __ ] rhymes
right so i wrote i wrote limericks for
you guys so oh and by the way megan you
just had to pick a different town there
once was an old man from
nantucket dilver
who drank so much you killed his liver
you know whatever silver liver don't
worry given thank you giving notes on a
classic fast enough giving notes on a
classic
megan this is really good megan you're a
delightful writer she's the best
who's going first who's going first i'll
go first okay because i i don't expect
my ability to continue to speak
coherently
let's raise our glasses to glenn
the best of the five-star men
he's the host of this show
can't stay safe on the snow
and he dreams
of not chewing again
that's very so good that's very very
good yeah a lot of references and if
somebody at home doesn't think that it's
good they're [ __ ] idiots
it's very good cheers cheers we'll go a
little bit for this one because then we
got three did i already drink mine you
said you didn't want it
i don't remember rob read yours
three cheers for our pal
charlie day yeah he's one of a kind
in a way
we'd flatter him more
but he'll walk out the door
and forget every word that we said yes
wait it's so good it's like god damn
that's good why did i forget something
that is good
well rob that means this one's about you
i guess so
you want to hear it
yes
what are you anticipating
well it's kind of out of the three of us
yeah i'm the one that's closest to megan
oh so you're anticipating a roast
i think it's going to be
roast devastating yeah roasty yes
but we have
we're very close so she also loves you
oh yeah we love each other very much
it's a love hate relationship as it
often is yes but she does i'm i'm
guessing she doesn't love you she likes
you but she doesn't know you that well
not not i mean right now i love
everybody yeah yeah
yeah the beauty of the whiskey but
you're keeping her
because of your sociopathy you're
keeping her that's not sociopathy that's
not so
that's not sociopathy that's growing up
in an air force family where you moved
around a lot and had to protect yourself
god that's a whole thing okay all right
that's the whole thing we can get into
that but i hold everyone at arm's length
got it
okay and i don't like that about myself
i
it's ingrained okay uh a toast
to our good buddy rob
he's the reason we all got this job
thank god he made sonny to prove that
he's funny
[Laughter]
cause little rose a big rose because his
other show
makes people sob
[Laughter]
god bless you megan god bless you megan
now um a good brain you got on you
listen we should huddle up
in the other room or send megan into the
bathroom or something and try to write a
limerick about megan on the white board
you feel bad the thing is nothing rhymes
with dragon it's one of those words
like i never had a nickname what are you
talking about rhymes
we could spend our whole goddamn life
better
oh
for someone as brilliant as
back-to-back
however i reckon however i reckon we
won't find one yes yeah i'll take that
cheers cheers
cheers
you guys i'm feeling a lot of love
for as much as we have
officially finished the bottle
we opened it
and we finished the whole okay we
finished the bottle
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up
i don't have the acoustic guitar i'm
trying to play along to the thing but i
didn't get
no i don't need the guitar i was trying
to play along to your song because it's
cool to hear
rob
also plays guitar very well as yes he
does
we all we all can take her on a guitar
we can tank her we can take her very
musical and we can do it a harmony which
is pretty cool we go
like you're like go ahead
[Music]
[Laughter]
why is it so satisfying to harmonize it
is so satisfying i grew up doing that
with my sister like we would sit in the
backseat of the car we would listen to
songs on the radio and we would sit down
you want to hear my like hippie version
of that yes because the harmony is in
tune with like whatever vibrations of
the planet like yeah we're getting in
some eckhart tolle [ __ ] yeah i don't
read that [ __ ] guy man he's not the
[ __ ] boss of me um
it's the same as like why why it feels
good to like
[ __ ] lay in water
you know like i don't know there's
certain like it's soothing it's an
elemental thing there's a frequency
there's a frequency there's a frequency
yeah that's an elemental [ __ ] fact
brawl
we're talking elemental facts today guys
[Music]
bro
okay i've i've got a question for you
guys related to music so if this were
your irish wake what song would you like
played oh
after your death like for people to rock
to
i think i have one but first i'll be
i'll be right back uh i think it'd be
like amazing grace like
you sing it
[Music]
like
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
that was amazing you guys
oh man well you do that at my funeral
when i die can you play fairy tale of
new york i think that would be the song
i would want which is oh sure i don't
know what that is
you don't know it either no what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
the best christmas oh it's the pope
yeah because it's happy and sad and sad
and happy you know what i never could
play other people's songs
because the only way i ever played music
was like to just make up [ __ ] kind of
like we're doing tonight yeah
and
i was sometime i learned a couple songs
but i didn't learn songs i didn't really
learn how to read music yeah and i never
could play like people were like hey
play this i'm like oh sorry man i know
how to do that well you didn't learn
[ __ ] you just you just like do a thing
that you want to do
you you don't know how to like you
didn't you like you didn't spend a lot
of time learning other people
i could because you they tend to be
there's 12 there's 12 notes so there's
not that i tend to overlap
but that's really interesting well first
of all your parents are music teachers
yes right so that's but it is
fascinating because like any the way
that i learned to play guitar is you go
well i want to play a song i know so you
learn how to play that song i did that
too i got a neil young like chord book
and i learned like
yeah heart of gold all the songs in like
decade and um but
i also was like from the day i picked up
a guitar trying to just like write my
own
things let's play a song you wrote
well he wrote by the way i remember you
for the gang turns black i remember you
coming in one day and having written all
the songs in like a day
in one day
you came in and you were like here's all
the songs well you know what the thing
is though i'm always like tinkering with
stuff my memory is the same as yours
in one night like you sent us videos of
like
a song seven or eight like every song
how they ended up in the episode yeah
not like a first draft yeah well i mean
it's not such a talent that i was like
able to be like here's
10 songs it was more like i've i've been
like tinkering with a bunch of songs and
ideas for many years and i do nothing
with them so let's use them on the show
yeah you're being you're being home
you're being humble i get that and i get
that but it's [ __ ] crazy
that one day in one day we got a [ __ ]
video of like 10 songs
like with you singing them and playing
them on the guitar
and then you know we gave them to cormac
of course and cormac filled them out but
like
yeah i mean i would love to do a musical
together i'm putting it out there
but i would like a broadway musical yeah
like a like right not but but of sunny
or of something else like something yeah
something else just like write this like
a book of mormon type like a book of
mormon type thing
i think it'd be really fun that would be
very fun but like i mean with i mean
trey and matt they didn't act in it
would we act in it
well we could because we're that good
[ __ ] good i have a game for you guys
can you guess what time it is right now
8 p.m anybody else yeah i'm going to say
it my watch is [ __ ] 7 44
[Music]
it's the children's bedtime uh and i i
you know i'm gonna be around eight yeah
it's right around eight that's why i
know what time it is sorry to crash it's
just you are in my own home
we're in my office this is not your
office it's our office
we've had a lot of whiskey tonight and i
am so [ __ ] happy to see you i'm so
happy to see you oh what a breath of
fresh air oh hi glenn
charlie i love your hitler mustache you
look nice
what
this means i'm gonna like kill everyone
and everything and this means i'm just
going to arrest you but i might take a
bribe well by the way
i apologize by the way uh should we do
the shot oh caitlyn yeah
well
are you drinking i've got cheers and
lime juice and bubbly water well don't
god bless you yeah one of you guys
this is foolish this is foolish this is
[ __ ] the dumb one this is the this is
the dumb one i think i've been listening
and it seems like it's been done for a
bit okay
that was the dumb one caitlyn do you
have any good drinking
st patrick's day memories
um
either with these guys or without them
i don't remember life without them um
it's been uh oh it wasn't like uh cause
it was so great it's just been we've
been together for a really long time but
it's also been really really great what
if we did what did we do what was life
before me that's right come on what was
life before rob i don't know uh
dicks and tall men it was just a big big
dicks and lots of drugs and very tall
handsome men um oh thank god that's over
but you know what their egos are big
and so it doesn't matter how big you are
it matters how big your ego is no it
matters how big you believe yourself to
be oh oh oh oh oh sure sweetie this dick
is giant you just don't know it hmm yeah
no one knows it
[Laughter]
caitlyn i heard you don't like winking
oh god no we were just talking about
this i was saying because when i get
drunk i wink a lot now i feel bad no no
i think if it was from you it wouldn't
be so creepy for me
if she [ __ ] winked at you out of the
blue that wouldn't be like oh
i wasn't expecting to tell you why would
you do that a man winking at me is like
this private thing that he tried to
sneak across without anybody else
knowing this is why and i want it all to
be public and if you're going to say
something to me say it out loud if megan
winked at me it would just be you can
wink at me
but i do not like a man
i love this about you i love this this
makes me so like i love this and so i
will wink at you i will get you
[ __ ] yeah
yeah you know it's a safe i do yours
still triggers
and i love it so much and you're totally
right because it is
don't try and sneak me like a sneaky
little note and nobody else knows about
it like if you're going to be
inappropriate inappropriate where
everybody else can hear about it so
everybody i can like confirm without a
paper trail yes i want to keep the chat
how am i going to track that what if i
say oh he winked at me how am i gonna
prove that
nobody saw it it was so sneaky and quick
i don't like it
megan you can wink at me all you want
let's do it i do but i for the same
reason it's dangerous i don't know what
it is about me getting drunk but i wink
a lot and then i wink at guys and i'm
like i don't mean it i don't mean it
it's just like an involuntary very
dangerous it's dangerous that's
dangerous
it is and i've noticed that i've done it
a couple times accidentally while
laughing and smiling like the week
and i'm like no no wait hold on and i do
feel compelled to be like i'm i'm so i
didn't mean to that wasn't a i'm sorry i
didn't i just went to smile i feel like
apologizing for it because wings are
terrible stop it everybody's stopping we
should we should outlaw and baby yeah
but if i winked to my wife would you be
okay with that
that's okay if you guys have a contract
and it's okay if rob winks at me it's
fine it's not creepy he's never winked
at anybody that's why i'm comfortable
that's why i'm
i want to see both eyes actually i want
to know you got it you got to do it real
quick can you close one eye it's got to
be a quick one yeah
see anybody in the
not no big deal
we think that there's part of you
all right we're all in the middle of
where's the camera do it to the camera
what i don't know what my camera oh this
is my camera i just did it
i mean she literally just explained it
yeah
i wasn't listening
caitlyn how many episodes of the show
have you seen oh yeah we were talking
about how you guys thinking you haven't
you haven't watched no i don't know but
like i'm curious are there hold on are
there episodes of the show that you've
never seen there were only a couple of
years there where rob was a little bit
so i think it was right before the glenn
howerton burnout
yeah yeah they're uh
so there was a lot of burnout and
because we were doing back to back to
back to back to back and for danny and i
was really fun because we were showing
up and you know
working for two and a half months out of
a year was no big deal you guys were
writing and editing and shooting and it
was a lot
um there were a couple of seasons where
rob was so in the editing room
constantly that when the shows would
come out he wouldn't want to
watch them with me and we had little
kids and we had a tiny amount of time to
watch tv together so i didn't see those
ones
but i always wanted to watch them and i
love watching them and i'm not one of
those people who's like oh i can't watch
myself which i don't judge i just i i
love the show and i think it's really
funny and when it comes on i see it and
also also i if i may and i could be
wrong please
correct me if i'm wrong i would say
you've got your priorities straight you
you've got other things that you're
concerned with you're concerned with
your the life of your children mostly
it's the kids this is this is a job yeah
you know what i mean which what
i do need to go pretty soon and put them
to bed but um i don't want you to go i
know how many how many shots have we
taken off so we did this a lot you're
looking at me but i haven't
got here yeah we did the three to start
i'm hammered then we did one after that
four or five six four least
six having another one i think six oh
megan good for you is that the last one
is that the newest one or is that is
that the one
okay should we do one more and call
tonight
because i'm drunk enough to be overly
i love you megan emotional here's the
question caitlyn is the whole reason i
got involved with any of you guys in the
first place what do you mean yeah
because she's the thing that made me
keep watching sunny
like she's the thing that really
i uh in my life i've had two major uh
female comedy influences one was molly
shannon on snl yeah yeah and the other
is caitlyn olsen on on
and the reason was because it's so
seldom you see a woman put comedy in
front of everything else in their
performance
and i just from the very first moment
that i saw i still remember seeing um
100 baby and you're doing that shot into
the monitor where you're where you're
shaving your face
and i was like she's going so hard after
the joke and she's not worrying about
like how complete lack of desperation
yeah and it and i felt so it was so
i i saw i felt power through that like i
really and i watched that and i was like
i want to be involved with whatever that
is you know like i don't think this is
the right form for it but like i grew up
really hating myself like really like
had a tragic accident when i was in
sixth grade i was i was hideous through
middle school in high school i i think
that's kind of out there but like i
really always hated myself and he
definitely hated what i looked like but
i always really really looked up to
carol burnett and gilda radner yeah
because they would
unapologetically just go for the
character they didn't care what they
looked like it wasn't about being a
beautiful woman it was about being just
[ __ ] funny and when i would uh really
uh
dig into characters i loved when it came
from the inside yeah yeah
what you looked like on the outside
that's when you felt really funny and
authentic comedy specifically but all
entertainment but specifically comedy
helps us process our wounds
like we all are we're wounded people
like we want to feel and foul we want to
feel great but we're wounded we have our
childhood insecurities and they create
these wounds and when someone leans into
it and doesn't fight against it says i'm
going to lean into the thing that could
be wounding i'm gonna be willing to look
embarrassing right when will ferrell
takes his shirt off and runs around in
his underwear and he's got a scar in his
belly and his butt yeah and he doesn't
and he seems okay with his
he doesn't seem to have the vanity to
say oh i need to look perfect it it
helps us feel better about our own
imperfection and i think that's why we
love our our comedic actors right yeah
it made me feel less alone
truly let's drink this last shot and
call it a night i already drank it i
didn't know it was katelyn
cheers guys so stupid
well should we do the sobriety test oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
standing on one fly
just you guys know can we have the
cameras working yeah
let's guess who's the drunkest do it
you're so sick
okay are we gonna predict it
probably the drunkest which is crazy
that you're not the drunkest do you
think i am he's in your way sir
what are you basing this on like behave
well actually i would say behavioral
changes yeah well he's just quiet
but i think i think
i think you've changed the most i will
say i'm i'm very drunk
i don't need to prove anything the
alcohol works
it does stop it it does job it's
studying fine job on me
it's done but i do but but
the real test the real test is the
[ __ ]
test yeah the actual test
the surprises let's do it let's all do
it let's do it let's see who passes it
the most on my path
no
she hasn't had the whiskey she's you
can't drink tequila drink you won't do
it no i'm saying i'm gonna pass you
won't do it i'll do it i thought you
said i'm a pass no i'm not gonna
we're going to see it on camera we're
going to talk about ross what is this do
you pass
okay she's already doing something she
hasn't been asked to do this is pretty
good but caitlyn you cannot use your
hands to balance you yeah yeah yeah yeah
first failure
okay what are you doing why are you a
yoga person
just just [ __ ] hang out yeah until he
tells you really it's really cool
i count for 30 seconds and you just have
to it's all just one leg one leg up no
hands the test is can you be cool no
hands no swaying okay can you just be
[ __ ] cool for like 30 minutes
can you be [ __ ] cool for like 10
minutes i don't know that i could do
this no swan no hands oh no no hands no
hands she's falling she's falling she's
falling no no
she's already fasting
that's about eight seconds
come on caitlyn no no no disqualified
okay you're out oh [ __ ] glenn you're
next yeah you've already found swan you
fought sit down okay swan you failed
oh
glenn hop up do your eyes have to be
closed no eyes can be opened eyes can be
opened but your hands have to be down
hands have to be down yes
yeah that's right
that's so difficult to do even if you're
dead sober to stand on one leg with no
no but is it not a swan just one leg up
just one leg up yeah you're doing it
like a swamp yeah
yeah yeah
all right what's the thing
okay
so
what she's doing is wrong yeah so yeah
so caitlyn sits down stop she's
peacocking okay what am i doing you're
gonna have
you're gonna lift your leg you choose
the leg
and then
just yeah hands down by your side arms
down by your side no swaying nothing to
help your balance
yeah
and now you're holding that
for 30 seconds
and you're not
using anything else
and you're not swaying
no little sway there's a little he's
that was good though
you're telling me that that a dead sober
person can stand there on one like [ __ ]
that what are your gymnasts get out of
here
i'll tell you right now you're all drunk
yeah i don't need to test that you're
gonna need to just tell you i'm
hammering but my point is you're gonna
fail that if you're sober there's no way
you can stand there dead sober with one
leg up you're balancing your entire body
weight on one leg without swaying in any
way and keeping your arms to the side
you're a circus performer [ __ ] off
sorry go ahead that's not that circusy
yes it is
what you're balancing your entire weight
a human being is designed to walk on two
legs so you're taking all of your weight
putting it on one leg you're not gonna
sway back and forth what's the next
thing next thing so yeah you're lined up
you're going to take nine steps heel to
toe
and then you're just going to pivot
right back around and do it
um okay so a straight line one foot
heel to toe next step nine steps one way
i don't want so don't do any of this
homework just do it this way turn around
and go back yeah heel to toe okay
i'm gonna focus in on the edit i'm gonna
focus in on charlie being nothing
oh okay well now we're getting somewhere
now we're getting so because you should
be able to do this right okay
okay
here are you've already found
[Music]
now we're starting here so the cops look
great okay buddy now we're starting okay
yeah yeah okay we'll start whatever you
want don't bother step on this how about
this pal we'll just
mr howerton
we'll start when he restarts would you
like
three three yeah okay
i get the cuffs by that okay that's
[ __ ] hard
you know what we like to do we like to
give people lots of chances at it
before we put you behind the wheel again
we're going to give you another chance
this is very complicated in many ways
for many reasons okay beyond the fact
that i'm [ __ ] hammered right yes
okay
dear
officer two
three
four
five one two three four passes
see how many steps saturn okay good one
to prove that i could walk in this
straight line
[Music]
now i i
oh and you fell right at the very stairs
i do think if i do that a part of it
that a part of it is that you can't look
down
you can't look down you can't you he was
just looking down you're supposed to
look forward oh my god that is so tricky
yeah so
okay so you're supposed to write right
right that's firm it's almost like you
can't aid your balance in any way that
would be looking good you can't aid your
balance we're gonna give
officer all i need to do is practice let
me practice
one
two
three
four no problem
there's little english on that
i think you would do that if you're
sober okay yeah boom
[ __ ] i was looking straight
ahead
[ __ ] none of us are driving home just
to be totally clear for the hell no no
we've all been driven here
but speaking of which uh by the way
we did it this is great we definitely
did it we did the [ __ ] out of it yeah
and um
[Music]
good luck editing this
jesus christ
god bless play us out charlie okay
please have something
a lot of pressure
we came
to be funny
but we searched for the truth
we
towed some yarns
got along in the tooth
but life's just that way
[Music]
if you're lucky that is
i guess i'm just
foolish
for living in bliss
for i
[Music]
am happy
i guess that makes me
awfully sunny
and that's why
[Music]
we're here
for we
[Music]
are sunny
even though we
seem
blake
sometimes it may appear
[Music]
but we
are
sunny
[Music]
because we're hopeful
in a way
and we're honest
with each other
and i guess that's
just the way
we appear
we are sunny
in our way
and this will be
what we're known for
[Music]
till our very
last day
oh my god
that's good man
wow
i don't know i just got actually
emotional stuff
that's the whiskey
let's keep talking
wow that just that just really got me
yeah that's what it's like
huh that's what it's like being with him
you know bringing both of you guys i
don't know what i said
[Music]
you